claude re bonjour bonsoir avec ce coup
d'état de l'armée peut-on dire que la
dame de rangoon a perdu son pari mais il
semble bien ré fait qu'elle a perdu son
pari mais il faut noter que c'était un
pari difficile un pari osé et cana au
moins le mérite d'avoir essayé
je pourrais me dire un mot sur ma route
aux soucis ça n'est pas n'importe qui
elle est née à la fin de la deuxième
guerre mondiale son père était un héros
de la lutte pour l'indépendance de la
birmanie
il a d'ailleurs été assassiné un an
avant l'indépendance en 47
sa mère était aussi une militante de la
cause nationale birmane
d'ailleurs elle a été nommé ambassadeur
de birmanie à new delhi en 1960 et son
souci à l'époque la route l'a retrouvé
là-bas elle ensuite fait des études à
oxford puis aux etats unis elle a eu 1
s'est mariée à un chercheur britannique
un professeur spécialiste du bhoutan et
du tibet et en 98 les revenus où elle
est revenue en birmanie elle a créé son
parti aussitôt naturellement été mise en
en prison et elle a eu le prix nobel
comme vous l'avez dit en 2011 elle a
alterné pendant 20 ans les séjours en
prison et en résidence surveillée
jusqu'à ce que les militaires
considèrent qu'ils étaient probablement
leur intérêt à ouvrir le jeu et par
conséquent et les eaux rédiger une
constitution la constitution de 2008 qui
leur donne beaucoup de garanties 25% des
sièges réservés aux militaires au
parlement indépendance totale des armées
par rapport au gouvernement maîtrise par
les militaires du ministère de la
défense du mystère l'intérieur et du
ministère des frontières est en dessous
de ceux ci en effet appris le papy
qu'elle pouvait partager le pouvoir avec
les militaires dans le cadre de cette
constitution
donc dans un système dual où il ya où il
ya où il ya où il y avait deux pouvoirs
et elle a cru que
les choses pourraient évoluer dans le
bon sens que c'était une transition et
d'ailleurs les électeurs l'ont confortée
là dedans puisque lors des élections de
novembre dernier
son parti a emporté une énorme majorité
à la chambre
cette chambre qui devait se réunir il ya
deux jours lundi et c'est précisément le
jour où les militaires ont fait leur
coup d'état parce qu'ils ne voulaient
pas que sept chambres se réunissent où
ils ont été naturellement mis en
minorité et cette chambre aurait
probablement tenter de mettre en marche
le programme de réforme de la
constitution pour avoir une constitution
plus normale qui ne réserve pas des pans
entiers de l'état à aux militaires
faisant les faisant ainsi échapper aux
gouvernements légitimement élus
donc on est dans cette situation il
avait tracé des lignes rouges
pourtant madame aung san suu kyi a
peut-être donné des gages ça
correspondait peut-être à ce qu'elle
croyait la même compromis sa réputation
et son aura dans les pays et dans les
pays tiers et notamment en occident en
laissant faire les militaires lorsqu'ils
ont chassé les rohingya et même en
allant défendre la cour internationale
de justice la position birman face à ce
que les rings a considéré comme un crime
contre l'humanité voilà donc on en est
là aujourd'hui
et en effet elle a probablement perdu
son pari
alors en scène sushis son image a été
écornée à cause de sa gestion de la
crise d'héroïne gas notamment de la part
de la communauté occidentale que peut-on
attendre aujourd'hui de cette communauté
internationale précisément
alors bien sûr monsieur byden a dit que
les états unis allaient prendre des
sanctions et les très probable qu'ils
vont prendre des sanctions
moi je note simplement que le général
qui dirige la junte qui a pris le
pouvoir et déjà sanctionné il est
interdit de séjour aux états unis il est
interdit de tous les circuits sociaux
facebook et les autres depuis qu'il a
chassé l'héroïne gars de leur territoire
donc d'autres sanctions vont être prises
du côté de l'union européenne aurait
feront réfléchir aussi aux sanctions
sachant que ce pays est l'un des plus
pauvres du monde et que les sanctions
toucheront durement la population
par ailleurs la chine effectivement
s'est opposé au conseil de sécurité à ce
que l'onu prenne des sanctions ou 20
minutes et l'avait d'abord une décade
une déclaration condamnant le coup
d'état et est bien la chine a des
intérêts considérables il ya trois
semaines le président xi jinping était
en voyage officiel en vers manille bien
sûr il a travaillé avec madame aung san
suu kyi qui avait un rôle de quasi
premier ministre de facto mais il a
aussi vu le chef de l'armée et il a
discuté de la réalisation de ce corridor
économique entre la chine et l'océan
indien qui précisément abouti dans un
port que les chinois veulent construire
en pays rowling à la dame de rangoon
peut-elle revenir un jour au pouvoir
selon vos clones blanchemaison écouter
j'en doute parce que elle a probablement
été échaudés par l'expérience actuelle
et que les rapports de force à
l'intérieur de la birmanie étant ce
qu'il est elle ne se prêtera
probablement plus à partage du pouvoir
avec les militaires elle a cru que
c'était possible et et bien l'expérience
actuelle lui a démontré que ça n'était
pas possible
cela dit elle a créé un parti qui est
très populaire
il existe une société civile en birmanie
les moines bouddhistes joue un rôle
important dans passé on joue un rôle
important aussi dans l'évolution
système politique et il est probable que
d'autres leaders émergeront les
militaires ont promis des élections dans
un an il n'est pas certain qu'il
respecte 7,7 ce délai parce que ils
autoriseront des élections que
lorsqu'ils seront sûrs qu'un parti qui
se rapprochent de leur sensibilité pour
aller gagner et naturellement pas si les
partisans de la motion ceux ci peuvent
faire un score de majorité absolue comme
ils l'ont fait en novembre dernier
merci maison expert en relations
internationales